y
[Música]
transportistas canadiense cerraron un
nuevo paso fronterizo como parte de una
protesta en contra de las restricciones
destinadas a frenar la propagación del
fobi 19 el llamado convoy de la libertad
ya cumpla un poco más de dos semanas en
ottawa al tiempo que ha inspirado a
otros países del mundo a iniciar sus
propios movimientos
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson viajó a polonia y bruselas para
discutir las crecientes tensiones con
rusia el mandatario dijo que se trataba
el momento más peligroso para europa en
décadas y reafirmó su cooperación en
seguridad con el gobierno polaco si el
país se ve amenazado
la justicia salvadoreña dejó en libertad
a una mujer sentenciada a 30 años de
prisión por cargos de homicidio agravado
después de haber sufrido un aborto
espontáneo healthy de 38 años ya había
pasado una década en prisión y es la
quinta mujer liberada antes de cumplir
su condena desde finales del año pasado
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos a encarar
los transportistas de ese país han
cerrado un nuevo paso fronterizo el
puente emerson en manitoba y continúan
bloqueando el acceso a la capital la
medida hace parte del llamado convoy de
la libertad para protestar contra las
restricciones por kobe 19 y que cumple
dos semanas en ottawa al tiempo que ha
inspirado a otros países del mundo a
iniciar sus propios movimientos
día y noche durante las últimas dos
semanas los camioneros han paralizado a
la capital canadiense
el llamado convoy de la libertad de
inicio para protestar contra la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación impuesta
a los transportistas que querían
atravesar la frontera entre eeuu y
canadá pero el movimiento ha crecido y
ahora condena las restricciones por ccoo
y 19 y al gobierno de ellos intruso el
amor no vote por él no le dinero ni voto
y sólo quiero jesmond
hosting sexto libro que dejes el
gobierno quiero que lo dejes por cumplir
complete la pelota está ha ganado
visibilidad global con manifestaciones
surgiendo en otras partes del mundo en
nueva zelanda camiones y caravanas
convergieron en frente del parlamento el
martes para protestar contra las medidas
sanitarias y los mandatos de vacunas
ordenados para algunas profesiones creo
que la protesta canadiense inspiró a
muchos mirandeses a salir y tomar acción
porque si la gente se sienta y no dice
nada nadie va a escuchar nuestra voz
el jueves la policía trató de dispersar
a la multitud 120 personas fueron
arrestadas un movimiento similar también
ha tomado fuerza en francia un convoy
partido de la ciudad de niza el
miércoles van hacia parís antes de
dirigirse a bruselas
o no
apoyamos el convoy de la libertad
estamos muy contentos de ver lo que pasó
en canadá y ver lo que ahora pasa en
europa y en el mundo venimos a apoyar a
todos quienes van a partir para defender
nuestras libertades como libertad de
cara a su llegada a la capital francesa
de la policía parisina ha prohibido de
las caravanas una protesta se prevé para
el viernes el primer ministro británico
boris johnson visitó bruselas para
reunirse con el secretario general de la
otan jens stoltenberg ante los temores
sobre una invasión rusa a ucrania desde
allí coincidieron en que es un momento
peligroso para europa la amenaza que
supone la concentración de soldados
rusos en la frontera con ucrania
soltenberg dijo que es necesario
prepararse para lo peor luego johnson
viajó a varsovia para reunirse con su
homólogo polaco a quien le reafirmó
estar listo para ayudar si polonia se ve
amenazada su visita se dio justo cuando
350 soldados británicos llegaron a este
país para reforzar el flanco de la otan
y mientras rusia realizaba ejercicios
militares en belarús
hoy mismo la unidad de comandos 45 del
reino unido ha aterrizado en polonia y
esos 350 efectivos se unen a los 150
británicos que llegaron aquí en
diciembre en respuesta a la
inestabilidad en la frontera con belarús
y response team station versión pura el
presidente de manuel macro ahora anunció
los planes de francia para construir 6
nuevos reactores nucleares en las
próximas décadas como parte de su
estrategia para reducir las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero la energía
nuclear proporciona alrededor del 70% de
la electricidad francesa y la mayoría de
los reactores que ya existen en el país
se construyeron en 1980 lo que significa
que su tiempo de vida que se extendió a
50 años podría finalizarse en la década
de 2030
la energía eólica marina se desarrollará
para aspirar a unos 40 gigavatios en
servicio en 2050 es decir unos 50
parques eólicos marinos este mismo año
pondremos en funcionamiento el primer
parque eólico marino pero también aquí
lo que hemos empezado a hacer es recrear
y desplegar un sector industria francés
y este miércoles la salvadoreña él sí
fue liberada de prisión tras una larga
lucha y después de cumplir una condena
de más de diez años por haber abortado
en el 2011 en el salvador donde toda
forma de interrupción del embarazo es
considerada ilegal incluso cuando se
trata de abortos espontáneos como fue su
caso al bastan para tiene los detalles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
le ha costado diez años y seis meses en
prisión pero él si finalmente recuperó
su libertad tras lograr conmutar su
condena de 30 años acusada de homicidio
agravado después de sufrir un aborto
espontáneo
gracias
gracias porque cada día
lucharon
y siguen luchando
por las compañeras de todavía han
quedado
ya son pocas
y sé que así como yo he salido este día
así también es un día van a poder
obtener su libertad y van a poder estar
costas en 2011 esta madre sufrió un
aborto por complicaciones obstétricas y
cuando buscó ayuda médica fue acusada de
haberlo provocado y fue procesada
penalmente
ya que el aborto está prohibido en el
país incluso bajo causales como
violación incesto o peligro para la vida
de la mujer algo criticado por los
colectivos de los derechos de las
mujeres como la agrupación ciudadana por
la despenalización del aborto
su errónea sentencia de 30 años por
homicidio agravado ha terminado debemos
seguir luchando incansable y
colectivamente para liberar a las que
siguen privadas de libertad sólo en las
últimas dos décadas 181 mujeres han sido
juzgadas tras sufrir complicaciones
obstétricas en el salvador a través de
la lucha del movimiento feminista desde
diciembre de 2021 5 mujeres con este
tipo de condenas han sido liberadas de
prisión pero no todos se han corrido de
la misma suerte como en el caso de
manuela que murió en la cárcel tras ser
condenada a 30 años por infringir las
leyes del aborto una pena condenada por
la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos
durante una visita a senegal la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen anunció un plan de
inversión de 150.000 millones de euros a
áfrica el dinero pretende ofrecer una
alternativa frente a las inversiones
provenientes de china en el marco de su
nueva ruta de la seda este plan también
se da cuando muchos estados europeos
buscan reducir la migración ilegal desde
áfrica impulsada en parte por la pobreza
y el desempleo
hoy estoy orgullosa de anunciar más de
150 mil millones de euros a través del
programa áfrica europa se trata del
primer plan regional en el marco del
global gateway dos meses después del
lanzamiento de la estrategia contará con
el apoyo del equipo de europa y se
aplicará en colaboración con ustedes
y millones de personas en el cuerno de
áfrica podrían morir de hambre si no se
les entrega ayuda alimentaria con
urgencia esta es la dura advertencia del
programa mundial de alimentos ya que la
región enfrenta a las sequías más
fuertes desde la década de 1980 la
amenaza de la hambruna ha obligado a
miles a refugiarse en campamentos en una
búsqueda desesperada de alimentos agua y
refugio
a las afueras de mogadiscio en somalia
miles llegan a estos campamentos la
amenaza de morir de hambre y no les deja
otra opción
algunos caminaron cientos de kilómetros
para llegar hasta aquí en una búsqueda
desesperada de comida y agua
estuvimos ocho días en la carretera
hemos sufrido y algunas personas han
muerto dos mujeres que nos acompañaban
en el viaje murieron de hambre para
aquellos que sobreviven el camino apenas
alcanza la comida los ingresos
hospitalarios de niños desnutridos ya
están en aumento en las admisiones
también han aumentado considerablemente
también las cifras de mortalidad de
estos niños con desnutrición aguda
severa en el programa mundial de
alimentos dice que los habitantes del
cuerno de áfrica se enfrentan a las
condiciones de sequía más fuertes desde
la década de 1980 advierte que millones
podrían morir de hambre a menos que se
tomen medidas
reynés y después de tres temporadas de
lluvias fallidas el cuerno de áfrica se
encuentra en medio de una grave sequía
que impacta a unas 13 millones de
personas
de que somalia se ven afectados el
ganado muere las cosechas se pierden y
las poblaciones se ven obligadas a
abandonar sus hogares
los pronósticos de precipitaciones por
debajo del promedio podrían traer aún
más sufrimiento en los próximos meses
las agencias humanitarias dicen que
necesitan más de 300 millones de dólares
para mantener a raya la hambruna en la
región
hasta que esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]